so wir kommen zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt und eine Redner hat
es schon angesprochen es geht um das
Kurzarbeitergeld Unternehmen und
Arbeitnehmer die Kunden könnten die
konnten und können ja in der
corona-krise leichter auf Kurzarbeit
zurückgreifen zeitweise hat eine
Deutschlands Unternehmen bis zu 10
Millionen Menschen Kurzarbeit angemeldet
zumindest so sind in der Pandemie auch
viele Arbeitsplätze erhalten worden das
ist mehrfach verlängert worden diese
Kurzarbeiterregelung nun ist es so dass
im Herbst und Winter ja vor allem ist
eine große Unsicherheit gibt wegen der
geschiedenen Energiekosten was kommt auf
die Betriebe also zu deswegen hat in der
vergangenen Woche gerade die
Bundesregierung die Erleichterung beim
Zugang von Kurzarbeitergeld um drei
Monate verlängert das ganze ist
perverordnung geschehen heute dieser
Gesetzentwurf der jetzt debattiert wird
da soll sichergestellt werden dass die
Bundesregierung auch bis Mitte kommenden
Jahres eben per Verordnung Erleichterung
und Verlängerung beim Kurzarbeitergeld
so ist der nötig sein sollte vor kann
erst die erste Rednerin Annette Grammel
die Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin im
Arbeitsministerium liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir erleben das Putin den sozialen
Frieden in unserer Gesellschaft in das
fahrtenkreuz stellt Energie wird als
Waffe eingesetzt wir erleben er will
unsere Gesellschaft sozial
destabilisieren indem er Öl und Gas
abdreht er will unsere Solidarität mit
der Ukraine untergraben indem er die
Preise hochtreibt aber auch diesen
Konflikt wird der Kriegsherr im Kreml
nicht gewinnen wir bleiben solidarisch
und sozial nach innen und nach außen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben
als Bundesregierung mit aller
Entschlossenheit gehandelt wir haben
entlastungspakete auf den Weg gebracht
sie sichern vor allen Dingen die
Menschen ab die sozial besonders
betroffen sind aber wir alle wissen ein
starker Sozialstaat brauchte einen
starken Arbeitsmarkt in der coronakrise
haben wir unser stärkstes Instrument in
der Arbeitsmarktpolitik eingesetzt dass
Kurzarbeitergeld und mit Erfolg wir
haben es geschafft Millionen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
den Betrieben zu halten ja das war teuer
aber Massenarbeitslosigkeit wäre uns
noch viel teurer zu stehen gekommen
und deswegen ist es auch in der
aktuellen Krise so wichtig dass wir auf
das Kurzarbeitergeld zurückgreifen
können dass wir schnell handeln können
wenn sich die Lage zuspitzen sollte wir
brauchen dazu eine neue gesetzliche
Grundlage weil die alte ausgelauft
ausgelaufen ist und zwar ist wichtig
dass wir mit den neuen
Verordnungsermächtigung für
Vereinfachungen und Erleichterung sorgen
können das hilft Beschäftigten und
Unternehmen aber auch der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit so kann darauf verzichtet
werden dass Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer in Zukunft ihre Zeit leeren
müssen bevor sie in Kurzarbeit geben für
Unternehmen kann die Erstattung der
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge wieder
eingeführt werden
zudem kann auf die Anrechnung von
Nebenjobs verzichtet werden sofern sie
nur den Umfang eines Minijobs haben
liebe Kollegen und Kolleginnen wir
wollen jetzt eine neue gesetzliche
Ermächtigungsgrundlage schaffen damit
wir nach dem Auslaufen der alten keine
Schutzlücken haben ich bitte Sie um
Unterstützung bei diesem so wichtigen
Vorhaben es sichert den sozialen Frieden
in Zeiten des Krieges herzlichen Dank
die Kurzarbeiter Regeln der
erleichterten Zugang der wird per
Verordnung von der Bundesregierung
entlassen heute geht es in diesem
Gesetzentwurf darum dass der Bundestag
die Bundesregierung sozusagen damit
ausstattet mit dieser Ermächtigung des
weiter per Verordnung erlassen zu
erlassen zu können also schnell zu
handeln vor allem Jana schimpke jetzt
für die Unionsfraktion
eines der wichtigsten
arbeitsmarktpolitischen Instrumente ist
dass wir in Krisenzeiten haben und man
muss aber dennoch festhalten und das ist
das dramatische an der heutigen Debatte
dass die ampelregierung immer noch an
einer Sozial- und Arbeitsmarktpolitik
festhält wie in hochkonjunkturzeiten und
ich will Ihnen erläutern woran das liegt
ich meine die in Anspruchnahme von
Kurzarbeitergeld gegen dramatisch zurück
wir haben in corona-zeiten mit dem
erleichterten Zugang zum Cook noch
4,6 Prozent aller
sozialversicherungspflichtig
Beschäftigten in Kurzarbeit gehabt zum
Juni diesen Jahres Sankt dieser Anteil
auf lediglich nur noch 0,8 Prozent und
meine Kritik die ich hier heute Äußere
ist gar nicht das Cook ist vielleicht
nicht einmal der erleichterte Zugang
aber meine Kritik zielt darauf ab dass
die Bundesregierung noch immer nicht
erkannt hat welche Maßnahmen wir jetzt
eigentlich bräuchten um Arbeitsplätze in
diesem Land zu erhalten um und die
Existenz von Unternehmen zu sichern es
geht nämlich
es geht
mir mehr um die Frage
wie man eine Krise überbrückt es geht um
die blanke Existenz und mit der
Einführung der gasumlage ich muss das
mal so fachfremd an in dieser
sozialdebatte hier einbringen
etablieren sie ein Instrument was dazu
führen wird dass ich Unternehmen vom
Markt in Deutschland verabschieden
werden meine Damen und Herren die
gasumlage führt dazu dass die
finanziellen Belastungen von Betrieben
Art steigen dass sie hier in Deutschland
nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig produzieren
können was tun Sie sie setzen sich ab
ins Ausland oder Sie machen ganz dicht
und da können sie sich Kurzarbeitergeld
auch sparen so bedauerlich wie das ist
das Kurzarbeitergeld hilft in dieser
Krise nicht mehr meine Damen und Herren
und statt einer gasumlage brauchen wir
ein gaspreisdeckel den haben wir hier
heute vorgeschlagen und das wäre
eigentlich die einzig wirksame gute
Maßnahme die unser Land die unsere
Wirtschaft in dieser Zeit braucht
die neue ba-chefin Andrea Nahles das
will ich an der Stelle auch noch mal
gesagt haben wie es kürzlich auf die
dramatische Finanzlage der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit hin wenn wir also davon
ausgehen dass möglicherweise die
Inanspruchnahme von Cook unter
erleichterten Bedingungen künftig
steigen wird dann wird es natürlich auch
teurer liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nur die 26 Milliarden Rücklage die wir
uns erarbeitet erwirtschaftet haben in
wirtschaftlich guten Zeiten die sind weg
die BA lebt von Steuergeld und braucht
sogar noch mehr nämlich zwei Milliarden
Euro zusätzlich
und was sagt die BA noch liebe
Kolleginnen und da haben sie eine
besondere Nähe natürlich auch politisch
dass sie nicht auf eine weitere Krise
vorbereitet ist wir sind nicht auf eine
weitere Krise vorbereitet wir können uns
solche Instrumente nicht mehr leisten
und deshalb und deshalb und deshalb wird
auch nicht ausgeschlossen deshalb wird
nicht einmal mehr ausgeschlossen dass
auch der Beitragssatz zur
Arbeitslosenversicherung künftig
möglicherweise steigen wird und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das noch als
letztes die größte Sünde in diesem
Vorschlag ist die weitere ist die
weitere anrechnungsfreiheit von Minijobs
diese Regelung haben wir in der
corona-krise eingeführt weil wir wollten
dass Menschen die nicht arbeiten gehen
konnten sich dennoch was in der
Landwirtschaft oder am Handel
dazuverdienen konnten dieses dieses Ziel
hatte dieses Instrument das wird jetzt
fortgeführt man kriegt Kurzarbeitergeld
und darf sich noch was oben drauf
verdienen können wir uns das wirklich
noch leisten ich glaube nicht meine
Damen und Herren machen sie weniger
leistungsausweitung machen sie mehr
angebotsorientierte Politik führen sie
in belastungsmoratorium für die deutsche
Wirtschaft ein bauen sie Bürokratie ab
schaffen sie mehr Flexibilisierung so
haben wir vielleicht noch eine Chance
durch diese Krise zu kommen vielen Dank
für die von Jana Schimke hier
kritisierte gasumlage die ja ab 1
Oktober gelten soll die wird derzeit im
Bundesinnenministerium auf
Verfassungskonformität geprüft ein
Sprecher des Innenministeriums hat
gerade heute gesagt noch mal diese
Prüfung läuft Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Hardeck hatte ja durchaus rechtliche
Bedenken geäußert nachdem meiner Juniper
verstaatlichen wird also das wird
interessant sein weil wie gesagt ab 1
oktober soll die gasumlage ja eigentlich
stark Beate Müller jetzt für die Grünen
die Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas und
Frau Schimke sie können noch zu lange in
dieser Woche über die gasumlage reden
das ist ebenso es geht hier um die
verfehlte Energiepolitik
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck muss
jetzt in kurzer Zeit wegen der
verfehlten Energiepolitik unsere
Energieversorgung in weniger
komplett umbauen wir haben deswegen ein
Entlastungspaket auf den Pakete auf dem
Weg gebracht und müssen jetzt schnell
Hilfen für kleine und mittlere
Unternehmen bereitstellen und heute geht
es um die Beschäftigten und den
Arbeitsmarkt um Sonderregelungen beim
Kurzarbeitergeld denn wir wollen
natürlich auch Kündigungen und
Arbeitslosigkeit verhindern
noch wissen wir nicht was durch die
hohen Energiepreise auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
passieren wird wir wollen aber
vorbereitet sein und geben deshalb der
Bundesregierung Werkzeuge an die Hand
und dabei halten wir eine gute Balance
einerseits kann die Bundesregierung
durch eine Reihe von
Verordnungsermächtigung mit dem
Kurzarbeitergeld gezielt und schnell
reagieren
andererseits ist das alles natürlich eng
zeitlich eng befristet bis zum 30 Juni
2023 und das ist auch angemessen denn
die Verbesserungen beim Kurzarbeitergeld
kosten natürlich Geld und sie dürfen
auch nicht zu Fehlentwicklungen führen
und das müssen wir natürlich nach einer
gewissen Zeit auch neu diskutieren und
zwar da wo solche Beratungen hingehören
in den zuständig zuständigen Ausschüssen
und hier im Parlament
mit dem Gesetz heute machen wir die
Bundesregierung handlungsfähig sie kann
den Zugang zum Kurzarbeitergeld
erleichtern Bezugsdauer verlängern
Unternehmen bei den
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen entlasten
die Leiharbeit einbeziehen oder eben
auch nicht und sie kann auch entscheiden
ob das Kurzarbeitergeld mit einem
anrechnungsfreien Minijob weiter
aufgebessert werden kann das bedeutet
falls es Turbulenzen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt gibt kann die
Bundesregierung schnell und bürokratisch
das Kurzarbeitergeld so ausgestalten
dass es wirklich den Unternehmen hilft
und davon
und davon profitieren natürlich alle die
unternehmen können ihre Beschäftigten
halten weil sie bei den Lohnkosten
entlastet werden die Beschäftigten haben
weiterhin Einkommen und Perspektive weil
sie ihren Arbeitsplatz behalten mit den
Sonderregelungen beim Kurzarbeitergeld
schaffen wir also mehr soziale
Sicherheit und die ist gerade in
schwierigen Zeiten ganz besonders
wichtig und deshalb hoffe ich und das
sage ich vor allem in Richtung Union ich
hoffe darauf dass wir das Gesetz nächste
Woche gemeinsam mit großer Mehrheit auf
den Weg bringen vielen Dank
für die afd-fraktion hat nun die
Abgeordnete gerritui das Wort
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
im Anpassungsgesetz zur Kurzarbeit gibt
es einige sinnvolle Verbesserungen den
wir uns nicht verschließen zum Beispiel
eine flexiblere Antragstellung oder die
Möglichkeit eines anrechnungsfreien
hinzuverdienstes aber ich frage sie mal
meine Damen und Herren von den
Regierungsparteien wozu ist denn das
Kurzarbeitergeld eigentlich da sie
wissen es doch für vorübergehende
Auftragseinbrüche einzelner Firmen oder
einzelner Branchen für eine
konjunkturelle delle von nicht länger
als einem Jahr
für einen flächendeckenden Einsatz über
mehrere Jahre hingegen ist es nicht
konzipiert und auch nicht finanziert
dass sie jetzt die corona-bedingte
Verlängerung der Bezugsdauer auf zwei
volle Jahren weiterführen wollen zeigt
doch sehr deutlich dass sie selbst nicht
an eine schnelle Verbesserung der Lage
glauben sie begründen ihr Gesetz damit
möglichst viele Arbeitsplätze erhalten
zu wollen das ist ein vernünftiges Ziel
das wollen wir auch die AFD möchte dass
es den Bürgern in unserem Land gut geht
aber dazu braucht es eine
funktionierende Wirtschaft und die haben
wir nicht mehr Ergebnis ihrer Politik
ungerührt schreiben Sie bereits jetzt
sind die geschäftserwartung der
Unternehmen für die nächsten Monate
äußerst pessimistisch
dank der zunehmende Proteste haben sie
das wenigsten wahrgenommen aber da sie
nur sehr Ungarn etwas wahrnehmen was
ihrer klimaideologie im Wege steht
möchte ich in dieser Erkenntnis noch
etwas nachschärfen nicht nur die
nächsten Monate sind für unsere
Wirtschaft äußerst prekär die von ihnen
angerichteten Verwerfungen könnten auf
Jahre hinaus bestehen bleiben vielleicht
sollen sie es ja sogar
oder haben sie sich wirklich überlegt
was danach kommt wenn vielleicht der
Krieg zu Ende gegangen ist oder gar
nicht zu Ende geht was frage ich wird in
den nächsten Jahren dann besser
die horrenten Energiepreise werden die
wieder herabsinken dazu brauchen wir
natürlich wieder preiswerte
Energiequellen
und den einfachsten und preiswertesten
Weg Schließen von vornherein aus nämlich
russisches Gas alles andere ist viel
viel teurer was wird dann aus unseren
über 7.000 energieintensiven Betrieben
und ihre Millionen von Arbeitsplätzen
sollen die einfach kaputt gehen oder
sollen die auswandern viele grüne sagen
genau das
energieintensive Betriebe haben in
Deutschland keine Zukunft sagen sie ganz
offen
meine Damen und Herren wir regieren
nicht es ist Ihnen hoffentlich klar
leider nicht dann ist ja besser aus
das praktisch die gesamte deutsche
Industrie energieintensive ist und auch
fast der gesamte deutschen Außenhandel
denn sie haben das bemerkt wir
exportieren keine Bananen wir
exportieren technologiegüter und die
sind praktisch sämtlich energieintensiv
und im international wettbewerbsfähig zu
sein genügt es auch nicht die aus
15-fach gestiegene Preise aus fünffache
etwa zu senken denn auch Preise
Energiepreise fünfmal so hoch wie vor
den corona-maßnahmen sind nicht
wettbewerbsfähig
auch nicht übrigens für unsere
inländischen Bäcker die ihre Brötchen
schon jetzt nicht mehr kostendeckend
verkaufen können das ist Politik vorbei
am Volk
und glauben Sie nicht dass Sie unsere
Gesellschaft mit immer neuen
entlastungspaketen und Schutzschirm auf
Kurs halten können die sind weder
zielgenau nach dauerhaft finanzierbar
sie sind mich gerade dabei ihre Lohn und
Ertragssteuern gegen die Wand zu fahren
wer die Industrie kaputt macht und
Millionen Arbeitsplätze vernichtet hat
auch keine Ertragssteuern mehr
und kann auch keine Schutzschirme und
entlastungspakete mehr in finanzieren
auch nicht über immer neue Schulden denn
unser credatorating wird sinken wir
werden nicht mehr finanzieren können und
wenn dann noch eines einer der
EU-Staaten den wir verbotene
Haftungsverpflichtungen gegeben haben
kaputt geht sind wir auch pleite die
Regierungen der letzten Jahre haben
schon schlechte Politik gemacht aber sie
sind gerade dabei unserem Land den
letzten Dolchstoß zu versetzen und dann
kommt auch ihr Kurzarbeitergeld zu spät
nach den corona-maßnahmen die
Bundesanstalt für Arbeit nämlich keine
Rücklagen mehr das heißt bitte zum
Schluss
aber der hat auch kein Geld mehr wenn er
seinen Arbeitsplatz verliert viele
achten Sie bitte auf die Zeit meine
Damen und Herren versuchen es nämlich
gar nicht mehr mit Kurzarbeitergeld weil
sie kein Licht mehr sehen am Ende des
Tunnels deswegen beenden Sie die
symptomkurrierung adressieren sie
endlich die wirklichen Probleme danke
[Applaus]
war das für die afd-fraktion sie ist
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Arbeiten
soziales Jens Beeck hier ist der nächste
Redner für die Liberalen der Teilhabe
politische Sprecher
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren so ganz genau weiß ich
jetzt gar nicht was ich sagen soll
normalerweise wenn zwei
oppositionssprecher da waren muss man
sich ja verteidigen aber wenn ich sie
gerade richtig verstanden habe
bestätigen Sie genau das was wir auch
sehen wir machen heute das absolut
Richtige indem wir diese
Verordnungsermächtigung vorlegen wir
bedanken uns zunächst mal dafür dass sie
das auch erkannt haben liebe Kolleginnen
von der Union und liebe Kolleginnen von
den
AFD Land so und dann ist aber ja die
entscheidende Frage Frau Schimke sie
haben ja im Grunde gar nicht zu der
jetzigen Verordnung gesprochen
und was wir hier heute machen nämlich
die Verordnungsermächtigung verlängern
ist genau der richtige Weg und das
wissen sie auch den wir in der
Vergangenheit auch schon hatten das
Kurzarbeitergeld gehört mit zu den
absoluten Preziosen im unserem
Sozialstaat
1910 sie werden das alle wissen das
erste Mal im Bereich der kali-gesetze
als Vorläufer
24/27 dann nach Hyperinflation das erste
Mal in das deutsche Recht gekommen sich
danach verstetigt das erste Mal sich
bewährt in den 60er Jahren das zeigt
genau die Dinge die wir heute auch haben
bei den kali-gesetzen mit
Produktionsunterbrechungen in der
Hyperinflation danach als richtiges
Instrument und wir wissen sehr wohl und
das hat die Kollegin Müller Gemmeke
gerade ja auch gesagt dass das nicht die
Lösung der Probleme ist aber sie ist die
notwendige Brücke in unserem
Arbeitsmarkt bis zur Lösung der Probleme
und sie ist an der Stelle auch durch
nichts anbieten und weil man ja zum Teil
den Eindruck hat sie wissen gar nicht
mehr Frau Schimke dass sie ja an der
letzten Regierung beteiligt waren wir
wissen alle noch die wir letzte Mal
dabei waren dass wir dass wir die
Beiträge zur Arbeitslosenversicherung
durch die große Koalition von 3,0 auf
2,6 gesetzlich und damit zwei weiteren
Verordnungen auf 225 und 24 abgesenkt
haben weil wir die etwa 26 Milliarden
Rücklagen hatten
und jetzt sind die weg wir hatten sie
deswegen
weil wir dachten
21829 hat etwa 20 Milliarden Euro
gekostet den Arbeitsmarkt zu
stabilisieren wir bräuchten jetzt nicht
mehr und tatsächlich das haben sie
gerade etwas ausgelassen sind wir jetzt
in einer Situation wo das
Kurzarbeitergeld so wie viel es andere
auch in einer multi- und Dauerkrise ist
mit der Folge dass wir ganz andere
Summen aufwenden müssen über 20
Milliarden im Jahr 2020 über 20
Milliarden im Jahr
pro Jahr genau
und jetzt ja das war Corona genau und da
haben wir das eingesetzt das ist auch
vernünftig gewesen aber wir haben es mit
genau den Mechanismen eingesetzt die wir
jetzt vorschlagen zu verlängern und wir
haben es vielleicht nicht ganz zielgenau
eingesetzt weil sie die gesamten
Rücklagen damit verbraucht haben und das
entscheidender Unterschied und das wird
überhaupt nicht hinreichend von ihnen
gewürdigt das hier ist im Grunde das
nächste große Entlastungspaket für die
Menschen die Unternehmen die
Beschäftigten in unserem Land wiederum
im Volumen von über 40 Milliarden Euro
in den beiden letzten Jahren die Milch
nicht mehr aus Rücklagen kommen Kollege
bitte kann nicht mehr ausrücklagen
kommen sondern wir haben sieben
Milliarden im letzten knapp 17
Milliarden im letzten Jahr sieben
Milliarden dazu gegeben erst als
Darlehen dann erlassen also wir Stärken
dieses arbeitsmarktpolitische Instrument
massiv mit Steuermitteln
und wir wissen im übrigen auch dass wir
das es war ein Darlehen dass wir
erlassen haben dadurch ist es ein
Zuschuss geworden wissen sie doch
Zwischenfrage dann habe ich die
restliche Zeit auch noch können Sie ihn
erklären aber vielleicht wissen sie es
auch so wer steht jedenfalls mal
fest steht jedenfalls mal dass sie die
Rücklagen eben nicht mehr hatten die
Vorsitzende der Bundesagentur war gerade
im Ausschuss
haben wir alle gehört dass jetzt auch
keine Rücklagen da sind sie alle werden
nachgeguckt haben bevor sich heute um
diese Debatte geben wir hatten mit 2,2
Milliarden Euro Aufwendungen im Jahr
2022 gerechnet das war etwa am 28 April
diesen Jahres schon verbraucht jetzt
sind wir noch deutlich höher und
deswegen werden wir wieder ein weiteres
Mal an dieser Stelle mit dem Bund falls
es dazu kommt dass diese Instrumente
genutzt werden müssen helfen und diese
fortschrittskoalition die diese
Bundesregierung tragenden Fraktionen in
diesem Haus bekennen sich sehr klar dazu
dass wir keinen Beschäftigten kein
Unternehmen und übrigens der mit unseren
Sozialstaat insgesamt allein lassen wir
tun was erforderlich ist zielsicher
wirkmächtig und ohne große Diskussion
wir freuen uns dabei auf Ihre
Unterstützung
ein letzten Satz an dieser Stelle will
ich noch sagen wenn wir in der
Zwischenzeit während Corona ein aufwuchs
des Haushalts der BR wegen der
erheblichen Ausgaben auch im Bereich
Cook auf über 60 Milliarden hatten dann
ist das nicht einhergegangen mit einem
aufwuchs an Stellen in der WA und
deswegen will ich an dieser Stelle ich
hoffe in unser aller nahm ganz herzlich
DANKESCHÖN sagen die Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeitern der br-dienst durch die
letzten Krisen gebracht haben und auf
die wir uns fest verlassen können auch
falls es zu einer weiteren Krise am
Arbeitsmarkt kommt dafür ganz herzlichen
Dank
sagt hier Jens Beek für die
FDP-Fraktion ja das Kurzarbeitergeld der
Zugang zum Kurzarbeitergeld ist während
der corona-pandemie mehrfach
erleichtert worden verlängert worden
derzeit liegt die Bezugsdauer die
mögliche bei 12 Monate die Betriebe an
Kurzarbeitergeld erhalten können
gesund mit dazu beigetragen dass nicht
noch mehr Menschen ihren Arbeitsplatz
verlieren deshalb unterstützen wir als
Fraktion DIE LINKE auch eine aus der
aktuellen Krise ausdrücklich die in der
Pandemie geschaffenen Sonderregelungen
für das Kurzarbeitergeld zu verlängern
doch kurzarbeit ist gut aber eine
Politik die verhindert das Unternehmen
überhaupt unverschuldeten Probleme
geraten und Kurzarbeit in Anspruch
nehmen müssen ist besser deshalb ist es
höchste Zeit dass die Bundesregierung
endlich für eine
energiepreisbremse sorgt und einen
echten Rettungsschirm für unverschuldet
in Not geratene Unternehmen aufspannt
das ist doch völlig grotest dass die
Bundesregierung bei diesen Fragen über
den gesamten Sommer nach meinem Eindruck
völlig untätig geblieben ist und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister lieber darüber
philosophiert hat ob wir es mit einer
Welle von produktionseinstellungen oder
mit einer Welle von Insolvenzen zu
betonen bekommen statt dagegen tätig zu
werden meine Damen und Herren
zweitens ich glaube es ist an dieser
Stelle dringend notwendig mein
vorwärtner ist auch schon getan die
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeiter der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit unser aller
Dank dafür auszusprechen was sie in den
letzten beiden Jahren bei der Kurzarbeit
geleistet haben gerade erst wurden wir
im Ausschuss für Arbeiten sozial ist
darüber informiert dass trotz alledem
weiter 100.000 Anträge auf Kurzarbeit
noch nicht abschließend bearbeitet sind
und wenn wir jetzt auf eine neue
Kurzarbeiter kurzarbeitswelle zurollen
dann sollte jedem klar sein dass darf in
der Bundesagentur trinkt mehr Personal
benötigt wird andernfalls werden
zumindest erneut andere wichtige
Aufgaben wie schon der Pandemie hinten
runterfallen das muss angesichts der
anstehenden Herausforderung tun nichts
vermieden werden
drittens wenn Sie wollen dass die
Kurzarbeit auch dazu dient beschäftigt
in den betroffenen Branchen zu halten
wiederholen Sie nicht die Feder der
letzten beiden Jahre sorgen Sie dafür
dass insbesondere beschäftige mit
niedrigem Einkommen eine bessere
Absicherung erhalten statt sie auf
Minijobs oder das Jobcenter zu verweisen
und führen sie dazu doch zumindest in
dieser Krise ein mindest
Kurzarbeitergeld von 1200 Euro für
Vollzeitbeschäftigte
noch ein Wort zur von der Finanzierung
formal ist natürlich richtig wie sie in
ihrem Gesetzentwurf schreiben dass mit
dieser Ermächtigung keine Kosten
verbunden sind sondern erst mit dem
erlassen einer solchen Verordnung Kosten
entstehen doch klar ist auch dass alles
wird Geld kosten und nicht wenig und ich
wüsste schon mal gerne mit welchen
Summen die Bundesregierung hier
kalkuliert und woher das Geld dann
kommen soll aus dem Rücklagen das haben
wir glaube ich hier gehört der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit sicherlich
nicht denn die sind aufgebraucht ich
befürchte dass sie auch hier noch keine
Lösung haben dass diese Verordnung in
Zukunft durch die gesamte
Bundesregierung erlassen wird und nicht
mehr alleine durch das Bundesministerium
für Arbeit und Soziales
und damit der Bundesfinanzminister auch
ein Vetorecht hat stimmt mich zumindest
nicht zuversichtlich was die Anwendung
der entsprechenden Verordnung angeht
ich mache Ihnen einen konkreten
Vorschlag wenn wir jetzt dazu kommen
dass das Steuermitteln tatsächlich
wieder die ba-zuschüsse braucht dann
bitten Sie doch zu Finanzierung
diejenigen und eine ziehen sie doch zu
der Finanzierung diejenigen Unternehmen
rein die Werte Pandemie tatsächlich
Kurzarbeitergeld in Anspruch genommen
haben und trotzdem Milliarden an
Dividenden ausgeschüttet haben das wäre
mein Vorschlag mit dem sie zeigen können
das ist ernst meinen und soziale
Gerechtigkeit auch in dieser Krise ein
Wert hat vielen Dank
Pascal Meiser war das für die Linken ja
die Zahl der Arbeitslosen in Deutschland
ist im Moment trotz weltweiter Krisen im
August nur geringfügig gestiegen es
waren 2,54 Millionen Menschen arbeitslos
gemeldet das entspricht einer Quote von
5,6 Prozent
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
in den vergangenen zwei Jahren
in der Pandemie hat das Kurzarbeitergeld
Millionen Arbeitsplätze gerettet die
Sonderregelungen im Bereich des
Kurzarbeitergeldes haben in der Krise
entscheidend zur Stabilisierung des
Arbeitsmarktes beigetragen wir konnten
mit der Kurzarbeit Menschen in wirklich
schwierigen Zeiten im Job halten und
wenn die Lage sich verbessert müssen die
Unternehmen nicht erst neue Fachkräfte
suchen die eingearbeiteten Fachkräfte
waren und sind noch da und können sofort
wieder loslegen ja es ist richtig
Kurzarbeit war und ist ein teures
Instrument aber Arbeitslosigkeit kommt
uns deutlich teurer zu stehen und
deswegen war es richtig und ist es
richtig auf die Kurzarbeit zu setzen und
an der Stelle möchte auch ich ganz
herzlich weil ich weiß sowohl in meinem
Wahlkreis auch das was wir von Andrea
Nahles erfahren haben dass es ein
wirklich harte Zeit ist für diejenigen
die das alles abwickeln müssen und
mussten in den in den Agenturen ein ganz
ganz herzliches Dankeschön auch meiner
Seite
die Pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei und
der russische antriebskrieg auf die
Ukraine hat schon jetzt erhebliche
Auswirkungen auf Lieferketten auf den
Energiesektor und damit auf Betriebe und
auf ihre Beschäftigten wir stehen also
vor allem insgesamt mit großen
Unsicherheiten behafteten Winter aber
auch das haben wir gehört der
Arbeitsmarkt ist robust Fachkräfte
werden gebraucht wir beobachten dass
sich die Arbeitsmarktlage und die
Konjunktur entkoppelt haben wir wissen
aber nicht Frau Schinke ob das so bleibt
was mit den Lieferketten passiert und ob
es nicht in einzelnen Branchen auch
besondere Entwicklungen gibt und genau
deswegen wollen wir vorbereitet sein wir
müssen und wir werden alles tun
Arbeitsplätze zu schützen und
Unternehmen die unverschuldet in
Existenznöte geraten zu helfen und neben
den wirtschaftshelfen die Minister
Habeck aufstellt ist das
Kurzarbeitergeld dafür ein ganz
wesentlicher Baustein um dieses Ziel zu
erreichen
die Bundesregierung hat schnell
gehandelt und die Verordnung zum
vereinfachten Zugang zu Kurzarbeitergeld
die regulärende des Monats ausgelaufen
wäre bis zum Jahresende verlängert wir
wissen nicht wie die Situation auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt in den kommenden Monaten
sich entwickeln wird aber sicher ist
eins am Silvesterabend um Mitternacht
werden nicht alle Krisen überwunden sein
und deshalb treffen wir Vorsorge und
geben der Regierung erneut die
Möglichkeit über dieses Jahr hinaus wenn
nötig die Erleichterung zum Zugang zum
Kurzarbeitergeld weiter zu verlängern
und weiter eben diesen
Instrumentenkasten auch zur Bekämpfung
der Krise zur Verfügung zu haben
das würde dann konkret bedeuten dass
Betriebe auch weiterhin die Möglichkeit
haben wenn mindestens zehn Prozent ihrer
Beschäftigten aber im Arbeitsausfall
betroffen sind einen Zugang zu haben es
müsste nicht weiterhin
zuerst Erholungsurlaub oder Zeitguthaben
aufgebraucht werden es müssten keine
Minusstunden aufgebaut werden das heißt
wir entlasten diese die Betriebe von
Bürokratie und das ist in Zeiten wie
diesen ein wichtiger Schritt
es ist insgesamt
ein Signal an Beschäftigte und Betriebe
in Zeiten wie diesen stehen wir weiter
an eurer Seite aber wir dürfen in dieser
Krise nicht nur Brücken bauen sondern
wir müssen in dieser Krise auch die
Weichen richtig stellen und deswegen ist
es mir besonders wichtig dass die
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge dem
Arbeitgeber nur bei Weiterbildung voll
erstattet werden können damit Anreize
gesetzt werden die freie Zeit mit
sinnvoller Qualifizierung auch zu nutzen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen große
Herausforderungen stehen vor uns als
Gesellschaft und es gibt nicht den einen
Hebel die eine Maßnahme die uns die
Krise vom Hals schafft wir werden an
vielen verschiedenen Stellen
gleichzeitig sachlich diskutieren und
klug handeln müssen ein Baustein in
diesem Netz aus Hilfen und Maßnahmen ein
Baustein um uns gut durch diese Zeit zu
bringen und gleichzeitig die Weichen für
die Zukunft zu stellen ist das
Kurzarbeitergeld und ich freue mich auf
Ihre Zustimmung
für die SPD-Fraktion und sie hat es auch
noch mal angesprochen die Bundesagentur
für Arbeit natürlich auch beim
Kurzarbeitergeld gefordert vor zwei
Tagen war die ehemalige SPD-Vorsitzende
Andrea Nahles die er seit August Chefin
der Bundesagentur für Arbeit in Nürnberg
ist zum Antrittsbesuch im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales hier im Bundestag
was wir heute diese Debatte miteinander
haben wir müssen darüber sprechen und
ich will uns alle darauf hinweisen dass
wenn die Ermächtigungen Kraft tritt dass
wir an diesem Ort keine Debatten mehr in
den nächsten Zeit zu diesem Thema haben
werden ich werde das Bedauern völlig
klar ist das Kurzarbeitergeld
unterstützte unsere Wirtschaft unseren
Arbeitsmarkt während der
corona-einschränkungen wirklich enorm es
gab keine Massenarbeitslosigkeit die
Arbeitgeber konnten ja qualifiziertes
Personal halten
aber das lesen wir uns als Gesellschaft
wirklich eine Menge Kosten der frühere
ba-vorsitzende Detlef Scheele hat das
mit 46 Milliarden Euro insgesamt während
der coronazeit abgechetzt das bedeutet
die Kassen sind nicht nur leer sie sind
mehr als leer und wir werden uns
natürlich die Frage stellen woher das
Geld in Zukunft kommen soll
die Situation heute ist aber in keiner
Weise mit der Zeit während Corona zu
vergleichen erst gestern war ich im
Gespräch mit Handwerkern in Dresden und
ich bin mir sicher auch sie haben alle
so eine Diskussion bei sich in ihren
Wahlkreisen aber ich will es trotzdem
noch mal zusammenfassen diese Handwerker
diese Mittelständler sie sind in einem
festen Klammergriff aus Inflation aus
steigenden Energiepreisen aus steigenden
Lohnkosten und Arbeitskräfte und
Fachkräftemangel und diese Kombination
ist neu und jeder einzelne dieser
Faktoren hat mehrere Ursachen so viel
gehört zur Wahrheit aber auch dazu jede
einzelne dieser Ursachen wurde auch
durch die Politik dieser Bundesregierung
in den letzten Monaten noch verstärkt
das Kurzarbeitergeld wurde ursprünglich
konzipiert Herr Weg sie hatten das
angeführt um zeitweilige
nachfrageausfälle zu überbrücken es ist
nicht geschaffen für das gleichzeitige
Auftreten von enormen Kostensteigerungen
lieferkettenproblemen Nachfrage Rückgang
es ist kein Instrument welches auf Dauer
angelegt ist und die Energiepreise
werden in den nächsten Monaten nicht und
zwar aus unterschiedlichen Gründen nicht
sinken
das Problem ist dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine dauert nun länger als sechs
Monate es war doch absehbar und wirklich
absehbar in welche Situation wir in
diesem Herbst laufen werden und wir als
cdu/csu haben das doch oft in den
vergangenen Monaten im Ausschuss
angesprochen das führt doch dazu dass
wir das Kurzarbeitergeld zielgenauer und
gerade auch für den Mittelstand mal
gestalten müssen jetzt bekommen wir aber
einen Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt der
einfach dasselbe System weiterführt und
ich muss schon sagen Deutschlands
Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitgeber hätten da
schon etwas mehr Aufmerksamkeit verdient
und hier hat mal das BMAS kurz
gearbeitet
weder BMAS noch die BA versuchen
Alternativen überhaupt zu skizzieren wir
haben Gesetzentwurf beim Punkt
Alternativen sucht der findet als
einzige Alternative den Gesetzentwurf
nicht zu verabschieden und da finde ich
da machen sie es wirklich ein bisschen
einfach
wie kann denn das Kurzarbeitergeld für
Dauerbelastungen weiterentwickelt werden
ich gebe da mal ein paar Anregungen
erstens die Abrechnung muss vereinfacht
werden die BH schiebt einen riesen Berg
an bescheiden vor sich her
das bringt Unsicherheiten in die
Unternehmen es kann noch nicht sein dass
eine Unternehmerin über drei Jahre nicht
sicher sein kann ob sie einen gegebenen
Zuschuss überhaupt als solchen verbuchen
kann und ich muss auch sagen die
betreffenden BA Mitarbeiter wären schon
ein anderer Stelle besser eingesetzt
wir brauchen auch einen besseren Bezug
zur konkreten
unternehmensrentabilität so können wir
mehr Genauigkeit weniger Gießkanne
ermöglichen und insgesamt kann auch am
Kurzarbeitergeld nicht vorbeigehen dass
ich die Arbeitswelt massiv verändert hat
hier ließ sie sich doch auch mal etwas
Neues wagen so dass Arbeitskräfte nicht
während des kurzarbeitergeldsbezugs
nahezu vollständig dem Arbeitsmarkt
entzogen sind
aber am wichtigsten wäre in der
aktuellen Situation dass die
Bundesregierung rasch zielgenaue
unternehmenshilfen umsetzen das
Entlastungspaket der Bundesregierung
vernachlässigt nicht nur die Wirtschaft
insgesamt nichts davon was sie
versprochen haben haben sie bislang
wirklich auf den Weg gebracht und jetzt
machen Sie einfach das Naheliegende
und verlängern jetzt Rasters
Kurzarbeitergeld aber ich sage Ihnen
damit alleine werden sie die Probleme
der Unternehmen nicht einmal ansatzweise
lösen dazu müssen Sie nämlich die
wirklichen Ursachen unserer der Probleme
unserer Unternehmen bekämpfen und das
bedeutet erstens senken sie rasch den
Strompreis und damit auch den gapreis in
dem sie rasch die verfügbaren
Kraftwerkskapazitäten erhöhen und sie
nicht vermindern
verzichten Sie auf die gasumlage setzen
Sie rasch Hilfen für energieontensive
KMU auf so wie sie es ja für
Großunternehmen bereits gemacht haben
ergänzen Sie das durch Kredite für
Unternehmen und ganz wichtig verzichten
Sie auch auf den Ausbau der
Grundsicherung durch das Bürgergeld sie
werden hier in Größenordnung der
Wirtschaft Arbeitskräfte entziehen und
das ist das Letzte was das Land momentan
braucht
also zusammenfassend
das müssen sie jetzt in einem Satz
machen das System und dem Arbeitsmarkt
zu stützen sie als Koalition sind jetzt
aber in der Pflicht durchdachte Konzepte
für eine Verbesserung der
unternehmenshilfen vorzulegen vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
und hat der Kollege Frank zürske für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin Abgeordnete
das Kurzarbeitergeld ist ein
Erfolgsmodell
es mildert einkommensverluster
bewahrt Beschäftigung und hält
Arbeitskräfte im Unternehmen und es ist
wirklich ja Unsinn Frau Schimke zu
behaupten dass wir das Kurzarbeitergeld
nicht mehr bräuchten mit dem
vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf ermöglichen
wir den Bundeskabinett flexibel von
verschiedenen Komponenten des Cook
Gebrauch zu machen wir beschränken uns
aber nicht darauf mit dem Cook ein
wirksames Instrument zur Abmilderung von
Krisenfolgen bereitzustellen zugleich
wetten wir das Cook in ein Set weiterer
Hilfen ein unter anderem
öffnen wir das Energiekosten
dämpfungspaket für weitere
energieintensive Unternehmen
für den Mittelstand will Robert Habeck
eine zusätzliche programmstufe
vorschlagen sie soll nicht nur das
produzierende gewerbeumfassen sondern
auch das Handwerk und
Dienstleistungswirtschaft das würde ja
ein zweistelligen Milliardenbetrag aus
dem Haushalt kosten aber das sollten uns
diese dringend benötigten Hilfen wert
sein
damit nicht genug aus den Einnahmen der
geplanten zufallsgewinnabschöpfung
werden wir eine strompreisbremse für den
basisverbrauch der privaten Haushalte
und KMU finanzieren
und wir brauchen einen gaspreisdeckel
für eine grundbedarfsmenge sowie in die
Niederlande gerade einführen und in die
britische Regierung jetzt angekündigt
hat und das darf nicht an mangelnder
Finanzierungsbereitschaft scheitern
[Applaus]
die Inflation ist ja nicht
nachfrageseitig getrieben sondern durch
die hohen Energiepreise bei Gas und Öl
angebotsseitig und muss vor allem durch
gezielte Investitionen in
Energieeffizienz und erneuerbare
Energien bekämpft werden dabei gilt es
die Situation gerade der kleineren
Unternehmen und der Handwerksbetriebe in
den Blick zu nehmen uns alle uns alle
erreichen doch dramatische Botschaft von
kleinen Unternehmen von Bäckereien von
Gärtnereien nicht mehr wissen wie sie
angesichts der gestiegenen Preise
insbesondere für Gas durch diesen Winter
kommen soll hinzu kommt
einzig abkühlendes Konsumklima das
belastet Unternehmen zusätzlich darum
brauchen wir jetzt einen breiten
Rettungsschirm auch für kleine und
mittlere Unternehmen und das darf nicht
an mangelnder Finanzierung scheitern
zentral ist es jetzt ökonomische
strukturbrüche und Arbeitslosigkeit
soweit wie möglich zu vermeiden und
nicht aus dogmatischen Gründen eine
mögliche Rezession zu verschärfen
aktuell haben wir nämlich nicht nur ein
angebotsschock aufgrund hoher fossiler
Energiepreise sondern es droht auch ein
nachfrageschock der zu mehr
Arbeitslosigkeit Firmen Pleiten zu
weniger Einnahmen und am Ende auch zu
mehr Schulden führt in der Pandemie ist
dieser Gefahr mit einer aktiven Finanz-
und Wirtschaftspolitik begegnet worden
Arbeitsplätze und Betriebe wurden so
abgesichert das jetzt nicht zu
wiederholen das jetzt nicht wiederholen
zu wollen stellt eine Gefahr dar für die
deutsche Wirtschaft und den sozialen
Frieden
ich komme eine Krise ist ja auch ein
Vielfaches größer als die corona-krise
in den Begriff bekommen können wir sie
nur wenn der Staat genug Geld
bereitstellt und die Energiepreise auf
ein vertretbares Maß zu senken diese
Verantwortung gilt es dieser
Verantwortung gilt es sich jetzt zu
stellen
das Wort hat der Kollege Bernd Rützel
für die SPD-Fraktion und er ist der
Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für Arbeits-
und Soziales liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen ich möchte zum Schluss der
Debatte mal etwas zusammenfassen und
hoffe dass doch Einigkeit der Trend
besteht dass das kurzarbeitergelt ein
riesengroßer Schutzschirm für alle
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
diesem Land ist für alle Arbeitsplätze
und aber auch für die Wirtschaft die ihr
Personal behalten können das ist doch
mehrfach angesprochen weil ich hoffe
doch dass jeder dieser Meinung ist und
grundsätzlich das für wichtig und gut zu
finden
ja wir sind seit längerem im krisenmodus
gestörte Lieferketten
Personalmangel Fach und Arbeitskräfte
die Pandemie die Inflation und jetzt
durch den brutalen Krieg von Putin in
der Ukraine natürlich noch mal mit
extrem hohen Preisen für Energie mit
Knappheit an Energie und natürlich
löst doch das Kurzarbeitergeld nicht die
Probleme alle aber es baut ganz viele
Brücken Brücken wenn es Unternehmen aus
bestimmten Gründen schlechter geht und
seit 13 März 2020 also seit zweieinhalb
Jahren sind wir doch immer wieder dabei
die Gesetze anzupassen unsere
Staatssekretärin Annette Krammer hat es
erläutert Dagmar Schmidt hat es
erläutert punktuell anzupassen und immer
wieder auch der Regierung zu erlauben
Möglichkeiten zu geben nachzusteuern
damit es schnell geht und dass man
flexibel sind
[Musik]
ja
Kurzarbeit kostet richtig viel Geld und
ich habe sie gehört Frau Schimke das
können wir uns nicht mehr leisten doch
wir müssen uns es leisten wir werden es
uns leisten weil wenn wir das nicht tun
dann wird es viel viel teurer mit
ungeahnten Folgen für die ganze
Wirtschaft deswegen ist er German
Kurzarbeiter Geldwesen der ganzen Welt
genannt wird ein Instrument wo wir stolz
drauf sein können liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und weil der Besuch im Ausschuss
arbeiten und Soziales vor zwei Tagen
unsere neuen Chefin der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit hier mehrfach angesprochen
worden ist dann sagte uns Andrea Nahles
der Arbeitsmarkt ist robust und
natürlich ist der robuste hat sie recht
er ist robust noch nie noch nie waren so
viele Menschen
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt
wie heute noch nie und gleichzeitig
haben wir fast 900.000 offene Stellen
aber nichts ist in Stein gemeißelt wir
müssen vorbereitet sein es kann sich
schnell was verändern deswegen brauchen
wir Spielraum deswegen haben wir diesen
geschaffen und weil am Ende dieser
Debatte mehr ein persönliches Anliegen
ist will ich einfach auch noch einmal
auf schnell und unerwartet was sagen
unser Rainer Keller wir haben den vor
zwei Tagen gesehen er war hier als eine
Arbeit gemacht und schnell und plötzlich
und unerwartet ist nicht mehr bei uns
wir werden immer an dich denken lieber
alleine
ja es ist noch mal hier von Bernd Rüssel
von der SPD-Fraktion zum Abschluss der
Debatte und sie sehen auch den
Blumenkranz in der in den Reihen der
SPD-Fraktion der Abgeordnete Keller
gestern unerwartet verstorben
ja es ist debattiert worden hier zum
Thema Kurzarbeit die Bundesregierung hat
in der vergangenen Woche schon
beschlossen dass die
kurzarbeiterregeln der erleichterte
Zugang zum Kurzarbeit bis Ende des
Jahres verlängert wird die
Rahmenbedingungen sind ja während der
corona-pandemie mehrfach verändert
worden was die Bezugsdauer anbelangt
beispielsweise heute hat man allerdings
vor allem hier debattiert auf Grundlage
eines Gesetzentwurfes der ermöglichen
soll das weiterhin die Bundesregierung
schnell handeln kann wenn es Not täte
das heißt das Kurzarbeitergeld rein
durch Verordnung verlängern aber auch
verändern könnte beispielsweise und da
zu gibt es eben diesen entsprechenden
Gesetzentwurf der geht dabei jetzt
erstmal in die Ausschüsse und wird dort
weiter beraten